so our big media companies cracking down
on conservative news we'll talk about it
a couple stories say they are plus
there's a Harvard professor who's now
being ripped apart for supposedly
supporting the alright is he will talk
about that too and the Obama library I
promised it to you yesterday you will
get it today I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
now you're gonna have to wait a little
bit more for the Obama library because I
promise you're gonna want to see the
pictures if you have not seen it it is
an atrocity I mean it's just an
aesthetic atrocity we'll get to that in
just a second plus project Veritas
actually does some something really good
today I've said this before about James
O'Keefe that James is he does some
really good stuff he can be hit or miss
but he did I think a service to the
conservative public today I'll explain
why first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Zeile so yeah you are
stressed out let's be real the holidays
are over and now you're back in the
workflow and everything is terrible
because the holidays aren't coming up
again for another full year what do you
need you need a massage that's why you
need to go over my friends over at Zeile
Zeile is all about getting a massage on
demand hey zo calm or heels iPhone or
Android app it's called ze e L calm and
you select from top local licensed
pre-screened massage therapists you
choose your favorite technique your
gender preference time and location for
your massage they show up at your house
with all the stuff they bring the table
they bring the oils they bring the music
it is bringing a spa to your living room
and it's on demand seven days a week 365
days a year they can be at your door in
as little as an hour it's private it's
convenient its quality its comfort I
know this because I've used it my wife
has used it my father is used to my
mother is used it my sister has used it
my mother-in-law has used it virtually
everyone in our family has been the
beneficiary of Zeile Zeo calm and right
now when you use promo code been at
checkout you got 25 bucks off your first
massage again 25 bucks off your first
massage when you use promo code been at
checkout and right now if you sign up
for their massage membership you get 20%
off all your massages plus a free
massage table and sheet set a $380 value
yours for free no initiation for you to
join the membership just a great
additional savings on top of the $25
discount you're gonna get when you use
promo code Benton so go to ze e l zo
comm or on zeals iPhone or Android app
make sure you use add promo code to
check out use my code Ben get 25 bucks
off your first in-home on-demand
massage makes for a fantastic gift for a
loved ones alrighty so let us begin with
James O'Keefe so James O'Keefe made some
real news yesterday because he had
talked to a insider over at Twitter a
former Twitter staffer and this Twitter
staffer explained in full living detail
is that Twitter apparently shadow bans
people where Twitter will downgrade
particular tweets prevent people from
seeing them I've heard this about my own
tweets in the past that Twitter that
I'll tweet something out and people who
follow me don't actually see the tweet
it's really disturbing here's a little
bit from the James O'Keefe
tape this is undercover tape with with
one of the members of the Twitter staff
[Music]
so count that will you and then your
discretion because they keep posting but
no one sees their context so they just
think that no one's engaging with their
content there's a low and here's what
they're saying so there's a guy named
Abhinav Padre was a former Twitter
software engineer and he says shadow
Manning takes place he says one strategy
is to shadow ban so you have ultimate
control the idea of a shadow ban is that
you ban someone but they don't know
they've been banned because they keep
posting and no one sees their content so
they just think no one is engaging when
they're content when in reality no one
is seeing it Twitter software engineer
Stephen Pierce said quote every single
conversation is gonna be rated by a
machine and machine is going to say
whether or not it's a positive thing or
a negative thing and whether it's
positive or negative doesn't and then
it's inaudible it's more like if
somebody's being aggressive or not right
somebody's just cursing at somebody they
may have a point but it will just vanish
it's not gonna ban the mindset it's
gonna ban a way of talking oh Linda
Hasan is a policy matter for Twitter's
trust and safety team which is the most
Orwellian name and they say they are
working on down ranking bad people it's
something we're working on we're trying
to get the bleep he people not to show
up it's a product thing that we're
working on right now and then there was
another guy who you heard at the very
beginning a guy named Owen awry who's a
Twitter content review agent and they
say that in the past they would manually
ban or censor pro-trump or conservative
content they said yeah and they said if
this is pro Trump I don't want it
because it's offend because it
offends me and I say and I say I banned
this whole thing and that it goes over
here and they're like oh you know what I
don't like it to Moe's right let's go
let's carry on
what's next they said that more
left-leaning content would go through
their selection process with less
political scrutiny okay this is not a
tremendous shock if you've ever been on
Twitter there's been a lot of talk about
this for years this has been rumored for
years obviously the people who have been
banned on Twitter and they're people who
I am not particularly fond of and some
of the alt-right Twitter trolls the
people who have been banned I'm not a
fan of their stuff but the idea that
they get banned and a bunch of people on
the Left don't get banned for similar
content from the left is just insane to
me it's not a shock that Twitter is
downgrading content we found out earlier
this week by the way that Google is
basically downgrading content from
conservatives how do we know because
right now if you go over to Google comm
and you search the name of the website
that I run daily wire which is 8 which
is a fully credible site ok most of what
we do is aggregate news from other
sources most of what we are doing is
taking the news and then adding a bit of
commentary to it so we're it's very rare
that we actually report original news at
Daily wire nonetheless if you actually
go over to Daily wire on Google and you
search daily wire there's something that
pops up and what pops up is something
that says on the right side of the page
writes about and then it'll show some of
our old pieces and then there's a thing
they click on and it says reviewed
claims ok reviewed claims are a bunch of
claims that come from Snopes and climate
feedback and factcheck.org in fact all
of the leftist fact-checking
organizations and Snopes is a left-wing
fact-checking organization they have a
nasty habit of taking a factual
statement or right-wing or makes and
then drawing some sort of conclusion
from that statement and then arguing
with the conclusion that they are
drawing from that statement PolitiFact
they do the same thing a lot of these
backchecking organizations aren't
actually fact-checking the fact that's
being espoused instead what they are
doing is fact-checking some conclusion
that they draw from the facts so for
example I remember PolitiFact's did a
very long review of a video that I did
about how many people in Muslim
countries have extremist beliefs my
entire video was based on poll results
from Pew Research at Global right it was
at the entire the entire video that I
did you can view it has several million
hits at this point is me just saying a
certain percentage of the population of
Pakistan believes suicide bombings are
OK for example so what did PolitiFact do
they couldn't argue with any of the poll
numbers out citing instead they argued
with my definition of extremist so when
I said that
extremists to believe that Sharia law
should rule they would say well that
depends on your definition of Sharia law
are they just saying the cheerio law
should rule in their own country or
globally okay that you arguing with my
definition that doesn't mean what I'm
saying is false right you're arguing
with my conclusion which is fine and
that's a matter of opinion that's not a
matter of fact
PolitiFact ranked my entire video false
though the most hilarious part of that
politifact fact check is that they did
their own calculation they found
something like twenty percent of the
entire Muslim population on planet Earth
was extreme by their own calculation
meaning that some 200 million people are
extreme and then in their own fact-check
they say but we don't want to draw that
conclusion or anything well we were not
comfortable with the conclusions that
were drawn the reason all this is a
problem is because there's an attempt
now to reassert gatekeeping from the top
there's an attempt that's happening
right now in real time to reassert the
gatekeeping of news and a lot of this is
driven by the fake news mania that the
left has pushed in the aftermath of
Hillary Clinton losing the election so
Hillary lost we can't just say she lost
because she's a crappy candidate instead
we are going to say the reason that she
lost is because of fake news it's
because people are putting out stuff
that was false now there are stories
that are actually false but they're
stories about how pizza gate was real
for example where there's no factual
basis to it whatsoever
okay that's actual thick news then
there's stuff you disagree with and
unfortunately because the left disagrees
with so much of what the right has to
say what you see very often is the left
actually engaging in a process where
they will shut down the the
dissemination of conservative oriented
news because they're saying it's a
factual or counterfactual that's not
true that's not true so you've seen
there's been talk about this on some of
the major on some of the major websites
it's certainly true on Google that how
you search on Google is very different
than the search results that you
received from another web engine like
Bing the obviously twitter has been
downgrading conservatives for a while so
what James O'Keefe uncovered here is
something that's very troubling it's one
of the reasons why for example YouTube
has gotten itself in serious trouble
they demonetised a video that I did with
Dave Rubin the other day which is the
least controversial political video of
all time they D monetized a conversation
I do with Blair white on transgenderism
which is a very friendly conversation
with a transgender person about the
pronouns that ought to be used in
addressing transgender people that was
demonetised
right YouTube has demonetised a lot of
university videos so much so the Prager
University is suing YouTube now is that
a lawsuit that can sustain I'm not sure
it can because these are all private
companies but it is certainly true that
we do have a troubling situation that
people should know about when all of the
major ways that you gain your news are
being curated by a bunch of lefties on
the top who are biasing the newsfeed in
favor of their own in their own favorite
political beliefs knowing that other
media outlets will praise them for doing
so so good on okie for doing this and
this is something you should keep an eye
on just because news is being downgraded
by an outlet does not mean that that
news is fake news I mean as I say daily
wire is is now has these reviewed claims
over at Google guess what doesn't slate
Huffington Post salon right none of
these have this right none of them CNN
none of them have the the the reviewed
claims aspect instead they're just using
left-wing fact checkers to fact-check
it's not just Daily wire by the way it's
Daily Caller it's the Federalists it's
only right-wing sites basically which is
just insane okay in a second I want to
discuss another way that the left is
shutting down debate but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
tracker so you lost your keys you lost
your wallet you're searching for them
again it takes you an hour you're late
to your meeting this has happened to me
so many times I cannot count my wife
used to lose her phone on a regular
basis like I know when I say regular I
mean like twice a day like every place
we'd go she turned me and say where's my
phone
what have to worry about that anymore
thanks to tracker tracker changes
everything when they released a first
tracking device
they changed the entire market now they
have the tracker pixel it is the whole
latest Bluetooth tracking device on the
market you put tracker pixel on whatever
you tend to lose your keys your wallet
your purse it is small enough to fit
anywhere and when you misplace an item
that has a tracker pixel attached to it
you can use your smart phone and a 90
decibel alert will help you find it in
seconds so this beeping noise even has a
powerful LED light so you can find
anything in the dark and if you lose
your phone here's the coolest thing you
lose your phone you can't find it okay
but you turned your ringer off so now
you're trying to dial it and locate it
by the ring but the ringers off so what
do you do well if you have the tracker
pixel you hit the track or pixel on your
keychain and it actually overrides the
sound settings on your phone and that
means that you can now find your phone
even if it's even if the sound is off
which is a super cool thing you can even
locate your item if it's miles away
because every tracker user is part of
the largest crowd locate network in the
world sort of like Waze except
finding your stuff tractor has a 30-day
money-back guarantee so you really have
nothing to lose check it out 20% off
your order when you go to the track our
comm / Ben that's the e th e track our
comm / Ben you get 20% off again that's
the tracker comm / Ben again it's one of
those things you don't think about until
it makes your life inordinately easier
and that's what the tracker comm / Ben
is where he's that / Ben's that they
know that we sent you okay so in other
ways that the left has been shutting
down to bait there is this tape going
around of steven pinker steven pinker is
not a right-wing finger a figure as
Steven Pinker is a professor at Harvard
I took the class when I was at Harvard
Law School with Pinker and Alan
Dershowitz which is kind of a fun class
and Pinker is of course the author of a
book called the blank slate one of the
things that makes Pinker controversial
among a lot of people on the left is
that Pinker doesn't believe in the
ultimate malleability of human beings he
believes that the reason he titled his
book the blank slate is because he was
saying that that perception of humans
that we are a blank slate and that we
don't have any natural inclination we
don't have any natural presets he says
that's nonsense and that means that
we're constantly battling with our own
nature in order to change well Steven
Pinker was doing a panel for spikes
magazine the unsafe space tour panel at
Harvard Pinker has come under fire
recently because he'll say things that
are true like women may have different
different interests in than men do in
the career space which may account for
some of the discrepancies between men
and women in terms of science staffing
right he'll say things like
statistically speaking blacks commit
crimes more often than whites and then
he'll explain why that is that that has
nothing to do with race per se it has
more to do with culture it has more to
do with history it maybe has to do with
they made a stir with poverty but he's
willing to say facts that people on the
left are not willing to say so Pinker in
discussing this starts talking about how
political correctness has really led to
the rise of the alt-right then what
political correctness has done is it is
said to a lot of people that you're not
even allowed to say facts like men and
women are different or that race has
commit crimes at different rates because
if you say that then people are afraid
of the conclusions are gonna draw so
we're talking earlier about how the
fact-checking organizations do this they
don't like the poll results that I cite
so instead they argue with the
conclusion that I say and then label the
polls that I say it Falls right this is
what Pinker says he says if he can't
even acknowledge the on-the-ground facts
what you're actually doing is helping
people in the alt-right because here's
the logic they're a bunch of people in
the alt-right and/or who are not even in
the alright yet and they will say listen
I'm looking at the statistics and what I
see is that black people commit more
crimes than white people on an average
per capita basis and then people are
muffled oh that's not true you can't say
that you're a racist and then people on
the right will say you know people who
not even on the right people who will
see that fact will say well if it's
taboo for me to even cite that fact
maybe it's taboo maybe it's also taboo
but not false to be racist about that
fact it suggests that the race is
inherently what's driving the crime
right if the politically correct people
would say that's a true fact now here's
the explanation that has nothing to do
with racism which by the way is not a
left thing and something that I do on a
regular basis when I'm arguing against
the alt right but the left won't do that
the left will and acknowledge the common
basis of fact instead they will just say
you're not allowed to mention the fact
because the fact itself is racist so
this is what Pinker says and Pinker just
got shellacked for this I mean he's just
getting destroyed by the left here is
what Pinker had to say in his own words
the other way in which I I do agree with
my fellow panelists that that political
correctness has done an enormous amount
of harm in in the sliver of the
population that might be I wouldn't want
to say persuadable but certainly whose
affiliation might be up for grabs comes
from the often highly literate highly
intelligent people who gravitate to the
alt-right internet savvy media savvy who
often are radicalized in that way who
swallowed the red pill as the saying
goes the illusion from from from the
matrix when they are exposed to the
first time to true statements that have
never been voiced in college campuses or
in the New York Times or in respectable
media that are almost like a bacillus to
which they have no immunity and they are
immediately infected with both a feeling
of outrage that these truths are
unassailable and no defense against
taking them
to what we might consider to be rather
repellant conclusion so here is a fact
that's going to sound regionally
controversial but is not and that is
that capitalist societies are better
than communist ones here's another one
men and women are are not identical in
their life priorities in their sexuality
in their in their tastes and interests a
third fact that is just not
controversial although it sounds
controversial well that is the different
ethnic groups commit violent crimes at
different rates now if you've never
heard these facts before and you stumble
across them or someone mentions them it
is possible to to come to some extreme
conclusions such as that that women are
inferior that african-americans are
naturally violent that we all ought to
be anarcho-capitalists and and do away
with all regulation and social safety
nets that the most terrorism in this
country is the fault of Muslims the
first time you hear them you're apt to
say number one the truth has been
withheld from me by universities by
mainstream media number and moreover you
will be vindicated when people who voice
these truths are suppressed shouted down
assaulted all the more reason to believe
that the that the left that the
mainstream media that universities can't
handle the truth so the politically
correct left is doing itself an enormous
just so we can stop it there so we can
hear him say right is that the point
here is that people are taking these
facts and then they're drawing the wrong
conclusions but when the left argues
that the facts don't exist it's driving
people to embrace the wrong conclusions
so he's anti outright he's trying to
explain why the politically correct left
is creating the alt right it's the same
stuff that I've been saying on this
program for years it's the same thing
that I've said about the identity
politics of the left that when you push
an identity politics that suggests that
race and ethnicity are primary you can't
be surprised when people who are not of
your race and ethnicity start to treat
their own race and ethnicity as primary
it's a mistake by those people they
shouldn't be doing it but you have to
knowledge the forces at work in the
universe that are pushing people toward
these nasty horrible groups and there's
no one who's more anti outright than I
am I think I can safely say that
considering that was their number one
target in 2016 and that I've been
ragingly anti outright ever since they
became prominent force in the American
in the American political scene Pinkert
just gets destroyed for this so they're
a bunch of people on the Left who think
now that Pinker isn't who's acting that
they think steven pinker the leftist
Harvard professor who is on the left
okay I took a class with him I've read
his books Steven Pinker is not a right
winger he's an atheist he he believes in
government programs big government
programs he's ripped as an alt writer so
PZ Myers of free thought blogs wrote The
Pinker sympathies lie with the alt right
that's an absolute slander he says I am
shocked that a Harvard professor would
promote such ignorance and falsehoods
but of course none of the facts that
Pinker States there are mildly
rebuttable they're not rebuttable and
Myers makes no attempts to rebut them
Joshua Loftus a professor at New York
University he said the Pinker's ideas
were worse than the edited clip they're
just amazing Jamelle Bouie of slate who
I've had fights with over over this sort
of stuff before he suggested that Pinker
had claimed that blacks cause crime and
Jews control the world which of course
is not what Pinker is saying right what
Pinker is saying is that there are black
people in America have a higher crime
rate but then he explicitly denounces
the idea that the race is connected with
the crime rate he says there are other
factors that are relevant in assessing
whether race is connected with crime and
to comes the conclusion that rates
causes crime is stupid right but people
are ignoring that because they're using
exactly the same sort of PC censorship
the Pinker is talking about the drives
people be all right hey professor Jesse
Daniels of Hunter College says if one
were saying writing a book about the
mainstreaming of white nationalism one
would certainly consider featuring this
as supporting evidence for one's main
point it's just this is insane okay
that's not real that's not a Pinker is
saying at all but that's the astonishing
thing about the left is they are so
utterly incapable of even looking
internally at what they've done to
promote this nastiness that instead they
continue to engage in exactly the same
tactics that make the nastiness
more likely and more and more prominent
it's really an incredible thing when
you're ripping down Steven Pinker it's
so funny when I was going to Harvard Law
Alan Dershowitz it was on the left and
Steven Pinker was on the left and now by
the time ya
there I graduated in 2007 now 11 years
later Steven Pinker is on the Steven
Pinker is on the right apparently he's
now an alt writer and Alan Dershowitz is
a Trumpkin okay I don't think that Alan
Dershowitz is Steven Pinker changed all
that much I think the left changed all
that much I think the left aside the
same left that decided that Larry
Summers who was ousted from the
presidency of the University when I was
there for stating that women may have
different aptitudes and interests in
science and math and men right that same
University now says that Steven Pinker
is is to be ousted the Steven Pinker has
to be targeted you wonder how people
like sam harris and steven pinker and i
all end up on the same side of the aisle
on this stuff and we disagree about
virtually everything else
maybe the reason is because the left is
so extreme and radical that they're
driving away an entire contingent to
people who just want to talk about facts
even if they draw different conclusions
from those facts I cannot have a
discussion with people will not operate
in the same world the facts that I
operate I can't have a discussion with
Steven Pinker and that I think is what
drives the left up a wall and so instead
they use censorship as a way of
preventing honest and open discussion
about issues that matter okay before I
go any further I will I do have to show
you the pictures of the Obama library I
think it does say something about Obama
as a human really I'm not exaggerating
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Skillshare so it's a
brand new year it is time for you to
make a resume deeper it is time for you
to broaden the skill set that you have
not just at your work but also in your
home life skills share is for that it's
an online learning platform with over
18,000 classes in design business
technology and more whether you're
trying to deepen your professional skill
set or start a side business or whether
you're looking to move careers
Skillshare is for you will keep you
learning in 2018 and beyond I've taken
classes in social media marketing other
people at the office have done the same
in order so that we can make our
business more efficient just in time for
the New Year Skillshare is offering my
listeners a limited time offer three
months of Skillshare for just 99 cents
so for less than a buck three months of
Skillshare check out their classes
they're all these 45 minute classes
taught by experts sign up go to
Skillshare comm Shapiro 99 again that's
Skillshare comm /er Shapiro 99 is from
Pier 99 because 99 cents for three
months act now for the special New
Year's offer start learning today once
you start you're not gonna want to stop
you're gonna want to continue learning
and learning lesson one of the things I
love about the audience for this show is
that it's an audience that's deeply
invested in
learning and I think that Skillshare is
perfect for that audience Skillshare
comm make sure that you go to Shapiro
99s is Skillshare comm / Shapiro 99 and
you get three months for just 99 cents
check it out okay so I promised
yesterday I was going to show you
pictures of the Obama library and they
are just incredible so here are some of
the pictures of the Obama library okay
this is Obama was approved this this
library really it looks like for those
who can't see it and are just listening
it looks like gonk from Star Wars
Episode four remember the robot with the
feet that kind of walks around
yeah there's gunk right so it kind of
looks like that alright so it looks like
gunk from it looks like a Chinese food
takeout box that was open and then left
in the Sun and it's it's it's this
weirdly Orwellian looking building it's
supposed to symbolize four hands coming
together which I don't understand at all
I don't understand how this is hands it
looks like just a weird building that
looks like a tower off the off the side
of the Death Star and it really does and
and then it has a Sports Center so
people can play sports at the Obama
Presidential Library and it's supposed
to overlook a walkway outside so that
you can look down on all the little
people it really is an amazing thing now
here's what it says about Obama look
look how hideous this is I mean this is
just hideous crap if you look at the
Bush Presidential Library it's kind of a
classy looking building if you look at
any of the old presidential libraries
they're all nice-looking the Nixon
Presidential Library is beautiful the
Ronald Reagan Presidential Library is
beautiful this is just a hideous eyesore
that apparently is being built by
modernists and those modernists do not
know how to build anything remotely
interesting looking it looks like it
looks like a Soviet bloc or a modernist
art piece just ugly is all sin my
goodness gracious and then my
understanding is that this weird segment
on the on the corner is supposed to be
words now I can't actually read any of
those words because I think they only
use the top half of the letters but it's
supposed to emphasize how important were
how important words were to Obama which
makes perfect sense because the guy
sucked at governing so words were the
only thing that he was good at here's
the part that I find really interesting
so in 2011 he said he wanted be an
architect did Obama so he said when I
was
there was a time I dreamed of being an
architect so as you might guess I've
been pretty hands on on the plans for
the sunroom and Michelle has too so
Obama who thinks he's an architect helps
come up with the plans for this hideous
hideous monstrosity that's not a shock
because you remember in 2008 he said I
think I'm a better speech writer than my
speech writers I know more about
policies on any particular issue and my
policy directors and I'll tell you right
now I'm gonna think I'm a better
political director and my political
director it was that sort of arrogance
and self-centeredness that led him to
being a bad president he was not better
at any of these things than the people
he delegated to and he is not a better
architect than my one and a half year
old child who can at least build a box
out of magna tiles okay this is hideous
crap and it's it's fitting for a hideous
presidency so there you have it just
ugly ugly ugly I don't know it is about
Democrats and ugly presidential
libraries here's a picture of the
Clinton Presidential Library let's go
grab that one this has been mocked for
years because it looks like a
double-wide trailer it's a very weird
looking Presidential Library in fact I
know a local radio host in Arkansas who
went and stuck a bunch of pink flamingos
in front of it as a prank because it
looks like a double-wide trailer it's
the I don't know why maybe maybe only
Republicans are capable of building
beautiful presidential libraries because
this one is just they're all ugly ugly
like okay so to get to some actual news
today the the President of the United
States decided to confuse everyone with
a couple of tweets this is the breaking
news so the house is now reconsidering
the renewal of the FISA Act the FISA Act
is the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act and the the FISA Act sets up a
system whereby intelligence agencies
have to go to secret FISA courts in
order to obtain warrants for domestic
wiretapping particularly and the idea is
that you're not supposed to give a
warrant for domestic targets you're
supposed to be targeting foreign
surveillance right foreign targets and
if people get caught up and that they
get caught up in that this is one of the
big arguments over whether Trump was
wiretap or manna fort was wire tapped
when the FBI was attempting to wiretap
foreign sources right when they were
looking for a wiretap on Carter page
where they actually for a wiretap on
Carter page if so did that violate the
Fourth Amendment or was that they were
having a wiretap on foreign sources and
those foreign sources were talking
Trump and talking to Manta for and
therefore they were sort of swept up in
this foreign intelligence surveillance
so the the Trump administration had come
out and endorsed the the RiRi offering
of section 702 702 again sets up
significant limitations on the Lawrence
that may be granted wiretap most
significantly quote may not
intentionally target any person known at
the time of acquisition to be located in
the United States and shall be conducted
in a manner consistent with the Fourth
Amendment to the Constitution meaning
that you could sue and say that you were
wiretapped wrongly and it would violate
the Fourth Amendment so yesterday the
White House press secretary gave this
statement they said the administration
strongly opposes the USA Rights
Amendment so the FISA Amendment
reauthorization act which the house will
consider tomorrow this amendment would
reestablish the walls between
intelligence and law enforcement thinner
country knocked down following the
attacks of 9/11 in order to increase
information sharing and improve our
national security so there is an attempt
to amend section 702 so that
intelligence agencies couldn't share
information as easily supposedly in
order to protect Fourth Amendment rights
but there was one problem Trump watched
Fox and Friends this morning so his
administration comes out and says don't
endorse us a rights Trump watches Fox
and Friends Judge Napolitano comes on
and gives a monologue at 6:47 a.m.
urging from not to back FISA
reauthorization and minutes later
minutes later Trump tweets quote house
votes on controversial FISA act today
this is the act that may have been used
with the help of the discredited and
phony dossier to so badly surveil and
abused the Trump campaign by the
previous administration and others
question mark so then he got calls from
his administration like people inside
saying mr. president we endorsed this
yesterday literally yesterday so 90
minutes later Trump comes out any tweets
with that being said I personally
directed the fix to the unmasking
process since taking office and today's
vote is about forward surveillance of
foreign bad guys on foreign land we need
it get smart so then ninety minutes he
has completely reversed his position and
by the way fibbed about this he's
directed the fix to the unmasking
process you can't direct a fix to the
unmasking process it's part of the law
right I mean the law itself would have
to be changed now does any of this
matter in the end no because I don't
think anybody takes Trump's verbiage on
on policy completely seriously but for
probably ninety minutes every Republican
in the world was panicking and for
ninety minutes all the Republicans were
going what
the world is he talking about and that's
why I think that a lot of the emphasis a
lot of the fear about what Trump is
doing on policy is a little bit
overblown
you can't take Trump seriously on policy
or literally on policy all you can do is
watch what the administration does
because Trump frankly doesn't know what
he's talking about on policy a lot of
the time we saw that in his immigration
meeting the other day when he reversed
himself on daca a clean deferred action
for childhood arrivals bill he reversed
himself on that in the course of 40
seconds when informed by Kevin McCarthy
that he didn't know what he was talking
about so a lot of his base is very upset
with him over this a lot of Trump's base
is very angry at him for supposedly
signaling that he's going to show
tremendous flexibility on illegal
immigration I think that his base is
getting out in front of itself I think
that a lot of the people like Coulter
Laura Ingraham Tucker Carlson I think a
lot of these people are taking from
literally and seriously and they should
not be doing either the reality is Trump
was having a meeting he thought of it as
a meeting he doesn't care that much
about the policy and he's not gonna be
the one who is setting policy as he made
pretty clear he said basically
congressional Republicans you're the
ones who are in charge of this I'm gonna
show you what I think the base is doing
wrong and how the media has responded in
just a second but first you're gonna
have to go over to the two daily wire
and subscribe for $9.99 a month you get
a subscription to daily wire yes you
it's a magical thing and when you do you
get the rest of this show why you get
the rest of Michael Knowles's show live
there are some Andrew Clavin show live
you get to be part of my mail back
tomorrow being part of the mailbag is
just a wonderful life experience it
doesn't just mean that you can write in
a letter and I will answer it it also
means that you can ask me questions live
preferably not about pudding and then I
will answer those questions and make
your life significantly better you get
all of those things plus you get this
mug this is massive leftist tears hot or
cold tumblr it holds up it is fantastic
it is weighty it has gravitas you get
all of that for 99 dollars a year when
you get the annual subscription so
cheaper than the monthly subscription
plus next week Andrew Klavan is gonna be
doing the conversation you get to ask
drew questions live questions Tuesday
January 16th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m.
Pacific that's when we are doing our
fifth episode of the conversation
featuring Clavin moderated by Alicia
Krause subscribe today to be part of the
conversation and you can ask drew live
questions he'll answer those for
everybody to hear you can watch it live
on daly waters Facebook page or our
youtube channel but if you want to ask
questions Walken is a subscriber at
daily where com go to
conversation page you can watch the
livestream there and then start typing
into the daily wear chat box and Alicia
will curate and funnel questions to drew
as they come in for an entire hour so
you have to subscribe for that and then
you get your questions answered by
Andrew Klavan on Tuesday January 16th
5:00 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific and
join the conversation ok or later you
can just go if you wanna listen the rest
of the podcast later iTunes SoundCloud
Google Play stitcher YouTube please
subscribe to our You Tube channel we
have great videos that are always coming
out we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all right so yesterday the base lost it
against TRO over over Trump's words on
illegal immigration so we'll start with
Laura Ingraham Laura on Fox who's been
an immigration hardliner through and
through she says that she is very
unhappy with how Trump was talking and
all I would suggest to to Laura I sound
like a trump can hear but I'm not hot
right I'm gonna suggest to Laura that
she is she's not trusting Trump enough
and what I mean by that is not that you
should trust Trump on policy you should
trust the people around Trump on policy
get some paint shaping the policy see
this is a great problem if you are a
worshipper of Trump personally is you
think this is all part of Trump's plan
you think that Trump is sitting around
playing that 40 Magne Magne Magne chess
that's not what's going on Trump is
saying stuff right
what-you-see-is-what-you-get Trump is
just saying things and those things that
he are saying he'll flip on them inside
of an hour already tweeted out a bunch
of stuff that completely contradicted
what he had said to Dianne Feinstein
about illegal immigration right he had
sent out his press secretary to say that
they would consider amnesty for illegal
immigrants and then five minutes later
they sent out pens to saying that they
are committed to the promises that they
made so here is it let's do Mike Pence
actually first and then we'll show the
reaction so Mike Pence the vice
president he's asked about Trump on
illegal immigration and here is the vice
president this president this
administration are absolutely committed
to keep the promises we made to the
American people I mean as the president
said last weekend at Camp David
there's no daca fix without a wall we're
gonna build a wall we're gonna end chain
migration we're gonna end the visa
lottery program and we're gonna deal
with daca but we're gonna do it in a way
that will meet the expectation of the
American people okay so there it is you
know pence basically is defining policy
I think a lot more than Trump is on a
lot of this stuff which is a good thing
right that is a that is a nice wonderful
good thing for conservatives but Laura
Ingraham and Carlson are very angry
listen I'll give them credit good for
them for actually being critical of the
president when they think the president
is doing something wrong
I think that they are under estimating
or they're both under estimating Trump
and overestimating from there are under
estimating Trump in the sense that they
are saying that Trump is gonna break
promises because he's not a promise
keeper I agree with that to a certain
extent they are overestimating Trump if
they think he's actually in control of
policy because he really is not here is
Laura Ingraham going after Trump on
exactly these grounds I'm gonna wait to
see
what the final doctor proposal looks
like but if it does not include a wall a
real wall not a see-through wall expect
a political revolt from the base which
means losing the house and maybe even
losing the Senate and by the way chain
migration absolutely necessary okay so
what she's saying there is is right on
policy we should build the wall the wall
by the way is like fourth priority in
terms of if you're going to reform
immigration the other priorities are Eve
Arif I making sure that employers aren't
allowed to hire illegal immigrants you
have to have also the the end of chain
migration so if you come in legally and
then you bring your entire family and
that has to be ended in the visa
well the visa lottery program has to be
ended as well the wall is like forth on
that list but in any case she's not
wrong on policy all I'm suggesting is
that all these people who are members of
the base listen I'm happy that they
finally arrived at the point that I was
at a while ago calling balls and strikes
with Trump I'm glad that they're finally
saying that Trump does something that
they don't like that they'll break with
Trump but if they think that Trump is
actually that yesterday was anything
more that his meeting with Democrats was
anything more than posturing I think
that that's wrong Tucker Carlson was on
the same page he was saying the same
thing on Fox News last night listen it's
good to pressure Trump I've been doing
it too welcome to party pal
Congress is full of people from both
parties who believe at the point of our
immigration policy is to provide cheap
labor to their donors and to atone for
America's imaginary sins against the
world they couldn't care less about
immigrations effect on you or your
family yet these are the same people the
president now says he trusts to write
the immigration bill the one he'll sign
no matter what it says so what was the
point of running for president okay so
he's not wrong on this but again I would
suggest that that Trump is not actually
the policies not gonna look like this
the policies gonna look like what
Congress shapes and whatever Congress is
able to get through the Republican
Senate they're not gonna get any
Democratic help on this the question is
what they get through the Republican
Senate I would hope that they get the
ending of chain migration the the ending
of the diversity Visa Lottery some
funding for the wall so Trump can claim
victory on the wall but the idea that
that Trump was serious about any of this
I think is utterly untrue the part that
I would be disquieted about here is not
what Trump does on immigration actually
the part that I would be disquieted
about is what Trump does when there's a
Democratic Congress which as I've been
saying now for four weeks is why
Congress matters and it's why Republican
scandals matter
so speaking of Republican scandals a
really bad Republican scandal broke
yesterday
okay it's it's it's not good so late on
Wednesday evening news broke that in all
likelihood we'll end the career of the
Missouri governor Eric Greitens he was
sort of an up-and-coming Republican star
at X Navy SEAL
so apparently he'd been having an
extramarital affair but that's not the
worst part of the story the worst part
of the story is that the ex-husband of
greetin's ex mistress came forward with
a tape in which the woman talked about
her relationship with greetin's and
apparently here's what happened this
according to the woman basically she
says that he invited her over to his
house that he told her that he was going
to show her how to do a proper pull-up
which is a very interesting come-on line
that she acceded to his request that he
proceeded to tape her hands to rings
blindfold her get her naked and then
take a picture of her and then take that
picture and say basically if anything
ever comes out about this this picture
is gonna hit the press so he's basically
attempting to use revenge porn as a way
to blackmail this woman allegedly now he
denies that he says the governor has now
seen the TV report that ran tonight this
is his team the station declined to
provide the tape or transcript in
advance of running their story which
contain multiple false allegations the
claim that this nearly three year old
story has generated or should generate
law-enforcement interest is completely
false there was no black clam blackmail
and that claim is false it doesn't
matter the allegations are serious
enough that this is now going to dog him
I think the chances that he remains in
office are relatively low again if this
woman comes out and says that this is
true particularly then it sounds it
sounds like this I wouldn't be surprised
there are other shoes to drop here if it
turns out that that this attack that
they did used before because that said
this doesn't sound like something you do
is one-off now you're gonna have an
affair and you just think of this on the
spot okay I'm to get you naked tape you
up and then I'm gonna and they're gonna
take a picture of you
yeah that sounds rather unlikely one of
the things that I find so disturbing
about stories like this is it does go to
whether character matters in politics
because there will be a group of people
undoubtedly who will say okay so he did
all this stuff can he govern right this
isn't this is where we but this is where
we've now landed I do wonder if we've if
we've hit rock bottom with this if
there's still people who are outraged
enough by this activity if it's true to
oust Greitens
or if there gonna be a bunch of people
who say the same thing they said about
Roy Moore which is okay well even if
it's true that he was allegedly
molesting fourteen-year-old girls even
if that turns out to be true maybe he'll
be a good senator right has character
gone so far
out that there's no way to bring it back
in and does that matter does that movin
discuss if it's been an ongoing topic
for a couple of years now among
Republicans does character matter at all
not doesn't matter a little doesn't
matter at all because we've been
continuously defining deviancy down
yes JFK was a perv but that was secret
from the American public and if the
American public had found out that JFK
was a perv in 1963 he's not reelect
ydynt eensy for yes LBJ was a piece of
crap but none of that information was
public knowledge so there have been bad
men who have been president before going
all the way back to the beginning but
though that was hidden from the American
public because the public did not
tolerate that and that does have an
effect on the culture that we all
inhabit together maybe it's true that
people of low character can be good
politicians maybe it's true the Ted
Kennedy can leave a woman to drown after
presumably having an affair with her and
leaving her in the back of a car in the
middle of the river maybe it's true that
he can go on to be a very powerful and
influential senator but what is also
true is that a society that suggests
that character does not matter when it
comes to people who are making policy is
a society that is going to treat
character as completely irrelevant and
that's I think where we are going is
Senator Daniel Patrick Moynihan coined
this phrase defining deviancy down in
1993 he wrote this about crime he said
over the past generation the amount of
deviant behavior in American society has
increased beyond the levels the
community can afford to recognize and
accordingly we have been redefining
deviancy so as to exempt much conduct
previously stigmatized and also quietly
raising the normal levels in categories
where behavior is now abnormal by any
earlier standard and this is certainly
not true only of crime it is also true
with regard to personal behavior of
politicians and that bleeds down to what
we accept in our personal lives not just
with regard to career but what you're
willing to accept in a friend right what
you're willing to accept in a community
what you're willing to accept in a
church these do have widespread effects
right there was a lot of talk after Bill
Clinton that there are a lot younger
people who are engaging in in oral
sexual activity because Bill Clinton had
basically made that a byword I think
that there's been statistics to show
that various types of sexual activity
that were hitherto considered taboo as
they are defined down as those are no
longer considered deviant they're tried
more often and then the human psyche is
just to look for the new taboo as we
continue to search for the new taboo
we're gonna continue to lower the
character of the American people it
doesn't mean every taboo is worthwhile
or that certain taboos shouldn't be
broken obviously there's certain taboos
that should be broken for example the
most obvious example be interracial
marriage which was a taboo for centuries
and that was broken and no harm no foul
not only no harm no foul I think
positive good but the idea that that
every taboo should be shattered and that
when we shatter taboos we're definitely
moving society forward instead of
backwards I think it's a mistake and it
leads to a lower character for the
American people for sure okay so in a
second I want to get to some things that
I like and some things that I hate so
let's do a couple of let's do a couple
of things that I like so we begin with
black mirror season four so black mirror
season four I've watched a couple of
episodes the first episode of black
mayor season four is really tremendous
if you haven't seen it yet it's called
the USS Callister that features Jesse
Plemons who's become one of my favorite
character actors I really like him and
he plays this this tech guru who
basically creates a Star Trek reality
for himself inhabited by other people
that he knows and it's it doesn't go the
direction you think it's gonna go it's
really it's funny it's it's it's
interesting it's our rated black mirror
it's always hard but here's a little bit
of the preview for season four of black
mirror it's hard to enjoy bright future
but we can and we must
anyone hello a stupid mental full system
nothing is gonna happen
[Music]
okay so the whole point of black mirror
is that technology is twisting us in
ways that we don't even think about and
that's why it's interesting to watch it
does raise some issues about exactly how
we treat technology that are worth
thinking about and that's what makes it
fun it sort of like Twilight Zone
but technology-based Twilight Zone
really good series if you haven't seen
the beginning episodes I say that season
1 is the best season 2 is also quite
good I thought season 3 was a bit of a
fall off what I've seen so far in season
4 I think is is actually better than
season 3 so check it out
Black Mirror season 4 ok other things
that I like so this I just found
hysterical apparently they're a bunch of
people on the Left who no longer want to
engage with with pink hats so
these are these are now a thing of the
past
these professor these people on the Left
are no longer interested in pushing it
why because according to the detroit
free pass quote the pink hat
excludes and is offensive to transgender
women and gender 9 but non-binary people
who don't have typical female genitalia
and to women of color because their
genitals are more likely to be brown
than pink yes peak wolken is as Jamie
Couric says just these people are
geniuses they are just wonderful
heartbreaking geniuses because genitals
are of different colors we cannot have
pink hats now we have to have
hats that resemble the actual
genitalia themselves I can't imagine why
you guys are alienating voters
I cannot imagine it please keep going
down this path because it's working out
fantastically for you God's people are
so stupid ok
other things that I like so there's a
story out and people are going crazy
over Mark Wahlberg was paid 1,500 times
more than Michelle McWilliams for the
reshoots on his on the movie what's name
of this movie all the money in the world
they had to reshoot it because Kevin
Spacey was in it and then they
Christopher Plummer and so they do
reshoot so Kevin Spacey oh so Mark
Wahlberg got 1.5 million bucks for the
reshoot Williams receives an $80 per
diem that amounted to less than a
thousand dollars and so people were like
oh my god William Morris Endeavor how
dare they not get great pay for Michelle
Williams she volunteered it's a free
country if Mark Wahlberg was smart
enough to understand that he had the the
studio over a barrel and he could do
whatever he wanted and you get paid a
lot of money that's fine also if you're
talking about box office draws there is
no
the mark Whalberg is a much bigger box
office try the Michele Williams and just
there's no doubt about it I mean just
look at the statistics it's not true I
love the idea that this is blatant
sexism as though Wahlberg's getting paid
more not because he's a better
negotiator but because he's a man not
because the bigger start but because
he's a man if that's the truth I'd like
to say I'd like to talk about pay
discrepancies on oceans eight where
everybody is a woman I guarantee you the
Julia Roberts was paid significantly
more than other women on the film in
fact Olivia Munn who does a a cameo in
the film says that she had to pay out of
her own pocket to be in the film that
they made her pay for her own costume I
promise you Julia Roberts was paid
several million dollars to be in ocean's
8 obvious sexism obvious sexism because
Olivia Munn is a woman and Julia Roberts
is a man or something this stuff is so
stupid you know before you start
claiming such as some racism privilege
why don't you look to the complicating
factors in the same way that before you
claim that race is responsible for crime
you might want to look to the
complicating factors so stupid okay time
for a couple of things that I hate
alright so a couple of things I hate
first of all I saw one of the worst
movies that I've ever seen I was on is
in a car from Las Vegas I had flown
there the flight back was delayed so he
drove there's a movie called good time
that just came out with Robert Pattinson
getting all sorts of great reviews it is
a full avoid this you know run the other
way it is so bad he's he's a very good
actor Robert Pattinson it is shockingly
he could take Robert Pattinson he's a
very good actor and Kristen Stewart
who's also a good actress and make
Twilight which is a horrific horrific
film right it's just an amazing truth
but this is a good evidence that good
acting doesn't mean good good movie good
time is just ah it's sure garbage
I won't even play any of the preview I
had our guys pull the preview I won't
play it because I wouldn't subject you
to that okay other things that I hate
this I have to show you apparently this
has become a new trend it's called pose
dancing it's a new dance style I suppose
and it's being pushed out there I guess
it's it's called figuring is the new
thing where you're supposed to form
certain figures here is what it looks
like
if you can't see this it's people who
look like they're about to hurl and
convulsing and posing what now it look
like they're about to be taken up by
aliens like that like that the beam is
about to come down or like they're being
controlled by an out-of-body experience
that's there on the end of it they've
got no strings to hold them down so this
is a thing okay if there's so let me
just say if there are a lot of worries
about white people can't dance before
this I think it is fair to say that
white people cannot dance is gonna
become a thing after this because what
the actual f what in the world are we
even looking at right now you know
remember that time when I said that art
is different from skill remember that
time when I said that that actual skill
actual craft matters when you look like
you're having some sort of seizure just
know just just just know okay I can't go
anywhere from there we're gonna have to
end the show there because it is blowing
my mind it's just it's too much guys
please don't do that anymore just stop
just stop the love God stop okay so
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest in news and opinion of course i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing